Marijuana is classified separately from other drug classes because its effects
are varied and complex. Cannabinoids are 66 chemicals unique to the cannabis
plant, which is what marijuana comes from. Delta 9 tetrahydrocannabinol, or THC
for short, is the most pharmacologically active cannabinoid similar to our
endogenous opiate-like endorphins. We also have an endogenous substance that
has marijuana like effects called anandamide. The cannabinoids and anandamide
interact with our CB1e and CB2 receptors. Our CB1 receptors are found in huge
numbers in the brain, but they're also widespread throughout the body. Our CB2
receptors are primarily found outside of the brain in immune cells. It's
important to know where the receptors are found because it can help us
determine why marijuana can produce the effects that account for medical use.